hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 god I love this game I really do
like for some reason the dead space
games have always appealed to me and I
wish I had started playing them sooner
but I guess I played later so I got I
didn't have to wait as long for dead
space 3 so either way I love the story I
love the atmosphere and I love the
combat now that I'm getting more into it
I got out of the noob phase I mean
starting out on hard was kind of giving
like shooting myself in the foot before
I started the race but you know I got
into it pretty quickly and I'm doing
just fine so Oh could this elevator be
slower one criticism about dead space
slow ass elevators come on ok here we go
I'm on the roof I guess oh what's that I
hear big make me make me go Billy go
Thank You Billy
all right up the ladder we go caution
high winds no harness for me to badass
oh hi I was wondering what the hell that
was the big dramatic for just a couple
little guys I wonder what it'd be like
to have your minds if you'd like the
guys that eat the necrotic flesh they
must have a slower transformation so I
wonder what it's like to slowly become
indoctrinated in this telepathic
community of diabolical demons I mean
now that I'm saying I want to try it but
it's just like something to think about
I I think about all sorts of stuff like
this what do we got rate of fire
clip that's not bad I need to find hunt
ha ha [ __ ] I need to find once battery
but there is no battery here I need to
find one where is aunt battery ah man
where's the battery I didn't see any out
there I guess you gotta find it up my
dear bin you must be somewhere up here
down there I have no idea really I
didn't see anything glowing and blue on
my way here is this he's ventilation
shafts and no battery Oh uh-uh Isaac
Clarke gonna get stuck it was pry in the
beginning that's probably it glowing
right there isn't it
no oh I see it I see it there's a
battery deploy if I'd have known that I
would have gotten it a lot sooner thank
you very much there it is okay I got it
give me that yes please thank you ha
Bisky I think I
by bomb
[ __ ] five river sir
I think these things are quicker than
they used to be they gotta be these
things are quick like bunny nerve I
thought you were still alive coming
after me now just a lifeless body
flapping and flailing over all right
let's see stick that in there and then
go around and get it in nothing could be
simpler up
over slowly making our way as the only
engineer on the team I do sometimes feel
jaded than I'm always sent for the
errand why can't I be in the nice warm
command center with Ellie's boobs to
keep me warm hi supply supply supply
supply I saw that you can't escape from
me not just a stasis pack I haven't been
using stasis all that much not my fault
really I just haven't had a need to bud
dunk
oh come on bud dunk okay there god damn
okay the furnace is on how's it looking
from whoa what what did I miss something
sorry I missed that jump scare I was
already on my way out okay I'm just too
badass
whoa no you're not even gonna get it you
always guy always getting I'm getting a
habit of just automatically looking
behind me whenever I uh whenever I hear
monsters spawning are you alright yeah
baby
hey thank you for not Robert you've not
been himself i nord just sing some
trouble in a couple of ways but you need
me for the mission and that's why I'm
here
that plus well frankly I hope Ellie that
Isaac great great you do having a nice
little chat just cool to say you got the
furnace going he's always way back now
Isaac season oh yeah sounds like a pair
of boobs I mean Ellie misses me Oh
looks like I got everything else going -
actually I didn't check the new suit I
don't know what new suit of
archaeologists suit is that because I
got wait hang on
is that because I got kabbaah see our
canola meal roofie body here each engine
I guess that's because I found more arca
archa our artifacts that's what I was
talking about yes
wait yeah his points ah tungsten you
bastard
odd oh so close all right I'll have to
wait till next time I've almost fully
upgraded my suit health and armor which
is good it's good escucha eyes boon de
ba don't know my hit caps locks I know I
got cap dog on the heat exchanges are
powered up now but the specimen isn't
flowing is there something wrong with
the mechanism yeah I think it's frozen
shut
maybe it will work it free by Jessie the
pressure in the pipe
hang on wah oh boy another strange
puzzle that I have no idea how to
operate oh I see it light up for there
so so then I hit four then what three
four
[ __ ] okay so start with four go to - no
how about one nope how about what what
well this [ __ ] doe makes a hole deaf I'm
an idiot okay 3 1 3 2 3 4 it's weird
that their entire technology is based
around Kinesis I mean I guess it's
really really good for heavy lifting
it's like seems doesn't even seem to
need a power source or anything
so uh
what happens if that thing wakes up the
internal temperature is rising what is
come up to the observation buoy I'll
explain it all the way the Necromorphs
are conduits for the market signals
while the research has built a sensor to
track that signal upstream to find the
machine so where's the sensor probably
destroyed but I did find the blueprints
to make a new one that's like I know
where this is going
haha I don't I'm just as confused as I
was before had dad sell hotdogs fell
haha sell uh cartel might as well just
sell most of these all right good enough
yeah don't even know why I bother to
sell the ammo I have way I have a lot of
scrap metal scrap metal is one of the
things that I have an abundance
hello baby oh yeah guess who's home oh
yeah uh you're not Nellie
I was telling you about probe god any of
the pots necessary to make this sense
off but there's another research
warehouse at the other end of the count
here's a schematic what do you think
okay that's something modified at
elementary spike I have no idea how it
works but yeah I think I can build it
with the right parts where's the other
warehouse cuz I'm an engineer
coordinates in your rig it is most
likely to be locked down tight here
I found these research pass codes when
we arrived I brought us into this
warehouse maybe there will work for the
other buildings as well well we'll find
out back soon
Oh Ellie's not even gonna say goodbye
huh yeah where is everyone else that's
what I'm wondering what's over here I
just got a check to sing out for myself
it's a giant Necromorph basically the
thing I killed on Aegis 7 why are we
heating it up it's gonna end badly I
know it is oh well come say comes off
whatever-whatever
didn't even get to sing here's a
question let's say this stupid
experiment works and you find the
machine they won you guys even have a
clue about turning it off well Admiral
graves referred to a codex she said it
was the key to controlling machine yeah
I've been able to decrypt several felt
this role of log and he records with
someone named Rosetta has been
instrumental in forging are you
listening to yourselves you don't know
any more about this [ __ ] than they
do if I can find the parts to make a
sensor we can find a machine then we can
figure out this codex business
unbelievable Oh aah aah
unbelievable oh I just can't believe it
ridiculous this Oh am i honestly hearing
this with my own ears
I'm such a dick I got my head so far up
my ass
then I can't even lift it up that smell
the roses anymore
Oh unbelievable ok anyway so I'm
starting to hate that guy more and more
at first he didn't seem so bad
well way to fail in your job to kill
Isaac Clark to set up some candles and
take the opportunity to kill yourself
what uh what a glorious moment to do
that okay they're mine
nothing nearby I'm going the right way
aren't it okay yeah and I miss this
afraid to clip one reload not good
enough not good enough worm right oh
hello was that scrap metal I got too
much grab metal Bing bong winner awesome
go man go oh not those things oh I hate
those little bastards I don't have my I
don't have my detonator I love my
detonator for those things oh that's the
gun that I'm missing I wish I had my
detonator maybe I could modify this into
a detonator somehow I don't know how but
guess I'll try what do we got a Lumley
major setback expanding facility one
glacier collapsed when three men lost
the supply-demand pyre serious setback
basically people died but they're more
worried about the project oh hello
I can't go over there what are you crazy
yeah yeah you better run you don't know
who you're messing with
I got a freaking rocket launcher I will
mess up your day oh boy
ah don't even try it
we're out okay oh it's like a friggin
nuke so awesome is one more I know this
come out come out wherever here yeah I'm
like a redneck on a rampage you can't
stop me but too close
and rocky lucky to finish up yeah
oh [ __ ] that was dumb
that was really dumb but totally worth
it haha oh no no no where am I going
anyway what the oh I thought that was
like a ledge into oblivion nevermind I
really wish I had the detonator though
because the dead Nader was awesome yeah
hey my ass huh wha wha there's a war no
I didn't think so I didn't think so far
too proud far too proud
nothing nothing over here oh hello
gotcha
artifact
yeah
it means despite our every precaution
contained it is now up to us to make the
ultimate sacrifice for the safety of the
sovereign colony Oh uh-huh we understand
we cannot expect 100% compliance
therefore the military arm of the spinal
cord team campaign will divide into
three tiers the first crew disables all
vehicles the next takes census of the
personnel obeys the order and provides
assistance to those who have not yes
destroys all data records and
communications man that would suck
I mean I know they probably told
everyone as they sign up hey there is
this contingency you're working with
dangerous crap but still having it go to
everyone and be like hey dang any time
to die
ha ha ah all right good - it is now up
to us to make the ultimate amount of
torque bars I think I need more these
that we have swore to protect there we
go I wouldn't have seen that we cannot
expect 100% I need to go make some
torque bars at the next bench lack
boughs
I don't like this haha
don't like this ah yeah that's right you
scamper off you too ha
and now I want you oh Jesus
anymore
I see you oh you can't hide from Mary
blah blah blah
is that the last of them
the chicks I'm definitely gonna try to
find a bench and I didn't even get to
the scavenger location yeah hey my manga
thank you have a nice day yep thank you
now as we move our way onward into
depths unknown I need to solve another
puzzle I didn't hit the I didn't hit the
medkit button what the hell was that uh
whatever it don't matter okay whoa God
oh man it's messing with my head Oh God
duh oh god oh man oh [ __ ] oh no no no ah
no ah my brain my brain that doesn't
work well with mouse and keyboard it
really does not uh-huh
oh okay
well anyway I'm too smart and too pro to
fail at it wait whoa
oh hey guys whatever they were
experimenting on here it looks like got
up and took half the warehouse with it
yeah what about the fence all time oh no
pieces right well it's a long shot but
I'll take a look around yeah maybe we
should be concerned about what we're
doing like I said before this thing it's
a thing that can kill never mind no one
ever listens to me duh I'm only Isaac
Clark the only professional hear about
Necromorphs I need a bench I don't even
have scavenger BOTS then I'm Blanche
goddamn good I need a Blanche what is
that
what am i doing oh I see what is that
well what I can't hurt whatever okay
well take a look I'll take a look at it
whatever could be i-i'll take a look I
got time out of my busy schedule to go
look at ah I knew it you bastard where
are you oh you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
snackies oh you mother
oh you son to beaches you sons of
[ __ ]
okay needed that can't get over there I
could but I don't feel like it alright
bench please need bench jaw okay
Santos lots of supplies apart for the
sensor excellent do you think you can
reconstruct it I just need to find a
bench you call it the blueprint yes
please
I need to dumb just gonna replace the
light ones with medium med packs here
and we're all fault
can't carry no more can't carry no more
okay where am I going
ah back up the ladder back up the ladder
I like how the parts are like right next
to each other that's awfully convenient
for me the player of games
ain't no Potter anybody want to step
okay nope carrying on moving forward
need a bench cash turn it need a
frakking bench thank you why can't I
upgrade my in blue hey old buddy I've
been been a while booth sorry you got
some things on your head I'm just gonna
clear it out for you thank you come
again
good side straight
oh wait no
ah there we go come on open up bam bam
bam
oh you son of a [ __ ] you're bad oh I
was gonna BAM you you you didn't let me
BAM you nah wash you guys got no
tentacles that's for sure
Oh to pro come at me bro
yes
idea BAM
your die you gonna die this time got
enough punishment no not yet
you want some more I got plenty actually
do I have tons of ammo more than I'll
ever ever ever out you said how stop it
come on move your tenant well there we
go
come on pretty
I don't know if I'm supposed to do
something when he's down I probably
should stasis more where are you going
I'll run it away like a little baby get
out of here
oh these thing keeps running away boy
works we will have the machines location
if this planet doesn't kill us first
we'll find it I'll be back soon why
don't they actually do something where's
Carter hey anyone been out to check the
armory no why [ __ ] that's what I thought
someone with the trail of flares are
still burning Oh God
you don't think Daniken is meno to find
out all right let's try it it might be
it might be someone important Howard's a
bench who knows there might be someone
that I need a rescue hi little Bailey
hey little buddy
good boy good boy all right god I'll
live
let's see select storage locations left
what okay I get it I need to actually
have this as a gun of sorts so I guess
it makes sense Oh almost 30 ration seals
not quite Anala
this looks pretty legal for science
equipment so what do I do with it the
research says the scientists took their
readings internally so I guess we have
to pry open the specimens belly well
that would explain the harpoon gun
good Oh grody okay there are people in
here I'm guessing people that I need to
destroy with my fancy new gun I mean no
science gun or science tool I don't know
what you want another bench wait a
minute it was just a bench downstairs
I'm kind of confused owner how big this
our merry can be hello it's big enough
to need a shuttle what the heck you
kidding me why is there a shuttle here
is there anywhere to go in this shuttle
last time I use a shuttle like this was
out in space why would I need one now oh
that's handy ah interesting
all right cool so it's like a fast
travel thing I guess the games a lot
bigger than I thought it was so there
needs to be a way to travel back and
forth alright anyway uh let's see here
where am I going
do whatever doing interesting where am I
headed I thought I just came up didn't I
just come up I'll say I have no idea oh
I see okay let's just get back to the
things we'll catch hola
I won't do as many optional missions as
I thought I was gonna do I will in my
separate playthrough on my own place of
optional missions just so I have
something to look forward to that I
haven't explored yet it's a little treat
for me because I like this game so much
and if you guys want to play the game
for yourselves it's there for you as
well precaution containment has become a
necessity yes it is
to us to make the ultimate sacrifice for
the safety of the sovereign college yeah
yeah what off we understand we cannot
expect 100% comply oh you kidding me
oh you're such [ __ ] okay all right
making my way back whoa what the hell no
you're a big guy ain't you no thank you
I don't want any that body is not really
gonna do you much good kind of I'm
almost dead what the hell what is that
what is that what is that hey let me use
my new gun see what it can do
oh that's what that was
Oh a suicide bomber ha may the markers
war didn't quite hear you at the end it
got kind of explosion II what okay there
we go
this locator is awfully handy I do enjoy
it
oh right almost there almost there
almost there ah I'm running out time
again
Oh looks okay Isaac I am done [ __ ]
around here Zdenek has shipped we could
take one get out of here if you care at
all about Ellie you will do this for her
haven't you been paying attention
we're the only hope of saving our entire
race there is no hope Isaac none the
best we can hope for is to survive and
get the hell off this planet really you
wouldn't risk the lives of five people
even if there are five people you care
for the whole for the whole of humanity
that's kind of dickish don't you think
selfish in a lot of ways okay anyway I
am all that time unfortunately so I will
get to this big event in the next
episode so thank you everybody summit
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that i've done
[ __ ] and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye